So, it was my birthday last Monday,
woohoo!
And, am I the only one that does this,
but whenever it's my birthday,
I sort of expect everyone to become
my personal slave.
Can you get my cell phone?
The cell phone that's...
right next to your hand?
But it's my birthday.
And it's not just small things like that,
like,
when it is my birthday...
I become...
a queen.
(British accent) Good morrow!
I beckon thee to my quarters.
Anna...
My fast of break shall be
bacon and eggs.
Make them green.
It's like 11:59 right now.
I'm not coming over
and making you breakfast.
It is my birthday, for minutes more,
and I demand birthday service!
Your accents suck.
I use the birthday excuse
when it's not even my birthday anymore.
But it was my birthday yesterday...
But it's my birthday tomorrow...
But my birthday only happens once every 365 days
and even though today is not that day
who's to say that I don't deserve to be treated that way
for my non-birthday?
Funny story,
My parents got me this director's chair for my birthday.
It had my name on one side and
the Batman symbol on the other,
and I loved it so much, thank you Mom and Dad.
I Instagrammed it,
and one of my best friends of like 10 years, Gaby,
texted me, and she was like,
"Hey...
I love your parents and everything, but uh...
that's...
the same exact thing...
that I got you for your birthday too."
And she was so disappointed
cause it..she felt like they stole her thunder,
but, I thought it was really awesome because
that was kind of... the best gift... ever...
the fact that the closest people to me
thought to get me something like that
kind of like, was like,
"Ooh, okay. I'm a director now. Yay!"
And I just--I'd--I really loved it.
And also, the story was funny,
and now I get 2 chairs.
Which is fuckin' awesome for everyone
who comes to my house.
Really quick, before I thank today's sponsor,
I am selling signed posters of my short films
on ghostandstars.com,
which is where I'm gonna launch
my clothing line in a few months, woo~
but yeah, if you wanna support my narrative work,
then I'd love for you to buy a poster.
And obviously you don't have to,
but, I mean, you probably would want to,
because then you could frame me,
and put me in your room,
so that I can watch you
endlessly,
as you make love to your significant other,
as you cry into the pillows when
he or she breaks your heart,
while you work and walk to and fro,
I'll be there.
Consoling you
with my endless stare.
Watching.
Waiting.
Experiencing your life with you.
Forever.
Every poster comes with that guaranteed.
(snickers)
I'd like to thank Zulily for sponsoring today's episode,
Zulily is an online retailer offering
top quality brands to its members.
They announce new sales
every day at 9:00AM via email,
with daily discounts of up to 70%.
They curate collections and make
online shopping fun and interesante~
You can also favorite certain brands to
get a reminder for when they go on sale.
I love the names that they use to classify clothing, like,
"European Touch: Sophisticated Apparel."
I was like, "That's everything that I want to be.
I want to be European and
sophisticated and wear apparel."
You can sign up for a membership
at zulily.com/anna
and get 15% off your first purchase.
That's zulily.com/anna.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Happy birthday to me, bitches!
Woo!
It's not narcissistic
when you have a lot of self loathing
and you just wanna
be reminded of your accomplishments.
Yeah.
I love you, baby.
Self love.
(snickers)
Little fuck..